bang-bang what's up guys lunch money
time Wednesday well Wall Street's trying
to get rich the rest of us just trying
to get a lunch money right I am here
with the beautiful Polina Mara Nova aka
she looks like a referee she'd be
working at Foot Locker right now yes you
do
sailor prisoner referee whatever you
want to call it we're good to go
what's up with the first topic contact
tracing
so Apple and Google have been working
together on something for the UK
government in the UK government but I
don't quite understand what the hell it
was
do you know what contact tracing is okay
what is that basically one like they're
trying to figure out when you come in
contact with someone based on your phone
yes so the whole idea of contact tracing
is they can do one of two things they
can use GPS coordinates so literally
your phone has GPS where did you go or
they can use Bluetooth which is
relational so you and I came next to
each other but they don't actually have
where the location is most privacy
people would rather the Bluetooth than
the GPS but still Bluetooth is not very
privacy centric well privacy centric and
accurate and it said that basically if
you were to go out like no matter who
you came in contact with it would say
like oh my god your Bluetooth the
Bluetooth is much more accurate than BG
yes yes because GPS doesn't work indoors
they can get messed up by like in New
York City if you ever walk out of the
subway and all of a sudden that's tells
you you're like three blocks or you're
not that happens to me all the time all
the time so bluetooth doesn't do that so
bluetooth basically make it easier now
the problem with contact tracing is
twofold
one there's a bunch of privacy concerns
around this because literally they're
tracking people right they swear right
you know scouts on or that they're not
going to use it for nefarious purposes
they're not going to label people
they're not going to build stuff I don't
believe them I trust no one and then two
is it's not improving to be successful
right so I had outs Gladstein the chief
strategy officer Human Rights foundation
he came on the podcast and he was
talking
like nobody even knows for sure if this
works so why are we gonna give up our
privacy in order to do something that
yeah the government says that they're in
it's gonna be helpful but we don't
actually have proof of it working well
we're not gonna have proof of anything
working because this is kind of
unprecedented race we have to try
something but they obviously is ahead of
the viruses there's been other viruses
this isn't the first Irish thing right
like contact tracing have they done have
they used contact tracing for anything
else before I'm not sure what the
history of contact tracing is but
normally contact tracing
I mean digital contact tracing the
traditional contact tracing is you think
that you're sick you come into an office
and then what may ask you they said
where have you been and you say I went
to work and then they call your work and
they say hey Glen Tamara no but we think
has Crona virus you should alert
everyone the office you should alert
everyone in the office that she has
pronin they should take you know the
necessary steps now what they want to do
is they want any digital contact tracing
which is essentially going to use your
phone so they know with 100% certainty
everyone you came in contact with right
but it's too late now
bang bang that's what I'm saying contact
tracing stupid and also on top of that
do you trust the government Apple or
Google to have the information of who
you came in contact where you went and
all the stuff I barely trust myself
what's going on the economy the economy
is shrinking I think you need to whistle
by the way like as the referee thing you
can't whistle
okay so with more than 26 million people
suddenly out of work that economy shrink
and a 4.8 annual rate in the first eight
months of the year which is which is the
largest the first globally contraction
the first quarterly contraction
sustained between the largest since the
recession of course and so anytime that
you get kind of these boom and bust
sizes right when you open and so
whenever you get these boom and bust
cycles there's at some point going to be
contraction did you know is a pretty
severe contraction for 20% is very big
yeah four point eight yeah I'll be the
Internet I know the numbers but a lot of
people think that that's just a first
quarter remember
coronavirus really didn't start to be
taken seriously and the shutdown's
everything until kind of like the second
or third week of March so it was just
the tail end but now people are saying
well what's happening q2 couldn't we see
10 plus percent contraction if we don't
get the economies restarted get people
back to work get people the consumer
else spending here's what I was talking
to my friend this morning about this and
what I told her was that it kind of
feels like we're you know how when
you're on a roller coaster and it's like
it's like at the top and it's like
wiggling a little bit shaking and then
it's just like it goes down really fast
I feel like we're right there and
nobody's ready for the bowing down part
is the market gyrating that's what it is
is gyrating like this were you talking
to your friend by the way were you
talking to your friend before after you
slept in until very late this morning I
was calling her out I was rudely awoken
you can't sleep all morning it's just
not possible people gotta get their
lunch money right we got work to do
so the economy's gonna shrink I think in
q2 it's gonna show an even bigger shrink
and obviously we can talk about this
over and over and over again the best
way to solve the economic problems get
people back to work you have to do it in
a safe and intelligent way because of
the virus but a four point eight percent
shrinking the economy's big 26 million
Americans tomorrow we'll get more
unemployment numbers probably another
couple million people and so the
situation continues to get more dire
while the stock market continues to rage
on which is another proof point that the
stock market is not a representation of
the economy what's going on the antibody
testing antibody testing so antibody
testing um some antibody tests had high
rates of false positives and screenings
performed by a consortium California
laboratories according to a recently
released report and here's where you
have got to be careful my friend is when
you read articles with the headline
coronavirus antibody tests have really
terrible accuracy researcher says like
okay I I always always when I see that I
always go back to the original source
and see their methodology because one
reason I could be a
you're a scientist though yes so it just
be careful like for a long time antibody
tests people have said you know they're
not completely accurate there's false
positives as false negatives whatever
but like just further proof that all of
the data is not accurate no all of the
data main one data point around co vid
19 that's accurate the number of people
infected not accurate the number of
people dead not accurate the number of
people through the antibody test not
accurate there's no data that is
accurate
it may be directionally pointing us in
directions it may help inform our
decisions okay that's fair but it's
still not accurate the numbers we are
being told or not a correction well here
here's the problem right is so an
example would be the antibody testing
shows in New York the cameras New York
state of New York City over 20 percent
of the population but they did antibody
testing on showed positive for Kobe 19
and they had been infected that would
suggest that there's a much higher
infection rate than they had originally
thought any much lower death rate than
they had originally thought the second
that you start to make decisions based
on that
and then somebody steps in and says wait
a second the antibody testing is
possibly inaccurate could be over
counting or under accounting no it's
just how are we making decisions and
begin it goes back to what I've been
saying for weeks now you can't make good
decisions on bad David are you just
supposed to be paralyzed in fear because
there's no good data like what are you
supposed to do no you you have to fix
the data and know what you fix the data
is you get more testing you have to get
accurate testing into the market you
can't rely on the antibody test or the
other testing because those produce
negative so what I think is gonna come
out of all of this when it's all said
and done we are gonna look back and we
were gonna say two things at the time
the information we had the right
decision was to overreact and to go into
quarantine and to stop the spread second
in hindsight with the data we now have
that was really stupid
and we actually shouldn't have done that
but we couldn't have known that until we
had the hindsight clarity of you know
20/20 clarity so
it's kind of a you know a circular
dilemma source and the worst part is
that everyone's gonna politicize so
literally all of these different
political parties all these different
politicians they're all they're all
gonna sit there and they're gonna say I
told you we should have done this I owe
it only the data showed what it showed
because we did the quarantine like all
of his nonsense what do you think we
should be doing Oh God well
president Covino wasn't ready for such a
question okay I'm a debate stage you
can't and I would have gotten like the
smartest people to start like testing I
don't know it's just it's really hard
when you don't have anything reliable
like how do you make a good decision
when everything you know is false or
inaccurate or amen ladies and gentlemen
if you watched the show long enough
you'll realize that she comes about a
week after I say something crazy and
controversial she comes around you're
already on the privacy bent you now
realize that to yesterday you were
asking all about deflation and the
devaluation of currency I was just
curious that doesn't mean that's what I
believe that's fine I appreciate the
fact that you don't believe what's going
on in college remember the master wrong
I love college remember that song you
hate that's one of course did you like
college I hate it I like the social
aspect of college I like playing
football I hated school
it was done but speaking of dumb kids
are now realizing this may be done and
what do they want do they want drop out
a bunch of students now we're saying
they're gonna drop out of college
because of Cara Myers so what does that
mean do they want to drop out because
they feel like I saw a bunch of students
we're suing their colleges because they
feel like what they paid for us all but
they got which is kind of fair also
imagine if you're a student like me and
you say to some degree is it sunny no
I'm doing this for YouTube user Gunny
Smith who said she would subscribe
I don't wear sunglasses all right time
out we're it's over we are not going to
cater to every single YouTube
look at what I'm doing to keep the
subscribers on your channel what are you
doing for the people to preserve the
subscribe I'm putting up with you that's
all that matters alright listen go back
to college you need your sunglasses on
students want to drop out of college
because basically they're saying is paid
I decided to go to school I'm paying
stop looking at me like that you feel
like you're like a female version of men
in black alright and so what they're
basically what they're basically saying
here is what they're saying is half of
the experience of college is the social
aspect I'm not getting that so why am I
actually going to school I can learn a
lot of this stuff online if I'm not
going to a top ten you know Ivy League
type school does the piece of paper
really matter and so you can naturally
just see a bunch of students questioning
what am i doing in college if I'm
actually physically going
I think they should question it in even
more so I think that absolutely like the
fact that you can take courses online
and if you honor to go in all Harvard or
Stanford or whatever I mean just
literally stuff online the best teachers
are on YouTube we are not teachers
Nerra no but the best teachers like you
can learn anything on YouTube you
literally can google anything even how
to make a chimp talk people don't have
that intrinsic motivation to go learn
things for themselves and they need
somebody to sign homework that's
probably true do you remember how much
enough of college do you remember like
the things that they taught in class I
mean I don't good a mom that's cuz you
were a nerd like literally you weren't
last night I had a drop on Polina she
said in high school she was in all the
smart people classes and it was cool to
be friends with the teacher and I had to
explain to her one we used to call that
a teacher's pet and then she said that
that was an outdated term and then two
was I said my relationship with the
teacher was basically one of you just do
the teaching I'll stay over here I won't
really cause too much ruckus and we'll
just be cool with each other but we're
not trying to be friends I'm not trying
to go eat lunch with you or do anything
crazy yeah I don't know I like saw the
teachers as peers such a nerd coming all
right last dance what's going on okay so
this is really funny
so if you guys have been watching the
last dance documentary um every Sunday
last Sundays
addition focused on Dennis Rodman and he
was wild but my name is Rodman I still
like Scottie Peter but my favorite part
of all this is that Dennis Rodman son
Dennis Rodman jr. was watching the
documentary we thought he knew
everything about his father's career in
life until they got to the part where
Dennis Rodman was like hey coach I
didn't need a 48-hour vacation to go to
Vegas in the middle of the season and
they're like wait what but they lent him
and in found him in bed with Carmen
Electra what else is gross is a
girlfriend Carmen Electra is his
girlfriend but the best part is I saw
meme after this came out and they said
if y'all ever want to know how good
Dennis Rodman was he had Michael Jordan
running through Vegas looking for his
ass to get him back to practice no let's
you do not just take a vacation in the
middle well in today's day and age
there's no way that they could do stuff
like that because that everyone's got a
cell phone
everyone's got social media like it just
wouldn't happen I remember maybe year
two ago Johnny Manziel in the NFL he was
supposed to like be at home and he took
like a sneak trip to Vegas and he
delivered he was wearing like a wig and
like a costume or something like that
like trying to hide his identity and
people have still got him on camera
posted it end up getting in trouble with
the team whatever can I have a hot take
for a second sure referee point what's
your take you got some water damage you
want you got such a watered-down
experience
you're a nerdy you don't like to do the
things that had little babies oh but you
know we did do we went to Cirque de
Soleil and he got pulled up on stage by
a clown and got to dance with it I was
doing a little shimmy up there in front
of a couple thousand people there
looking at my moves I was asking where's
the paycheck afterwards don't get money
gets me all right what uh any last words
for the people about last dance yeah
anything else did you learn anything
else other than Dennis Rodman's the man
you you didn't even get to see they
didn't show a picture of him wearing a
wedding
those one again those pistols pistols
the Detroit pistols piston this piston
oh they're not pistols the Detroit
Pistons horse just keep just keep going
okay well do you guys see what I deal
with on a daily basis they were pretty
violent there for a second yeah they
were the bad boys
they stole bad boys no they saw it sorry
there's quite Pistons fans watch it as
that's fine I'm a Knicks fan like
whatever it sucks what fan of mine oh
you're no you're a New York Knicks fan
you have to suffer I even even I know
the Mets are butter that's a holding the
Mets up to just so you know the Mets
play baseball sound the same okay so the
Mets in the mixer you're definitely not
a referee we're gonna go back to you
might be a prisoner or a sale something
okay okay so okay going back to our
discussion from last week if would I be
the Michael Jordan the Dennis Rodman or
the Scottie Pippen of what a basketball
of basketball yeah well when you play
basketball I get really violent in
sports you should have seen you play
soccer I was knocking girls down
couldn't do what jealous but I could
knock them down somehow you're more like
the John of paxton or the Toni Kukoc I
like John Paxson I haven't gotten to
Toni yet yeah Toni Kukoc is coming okay
and you have some won a championship I
like to clacks than guy John Paxton we
have the pistols the Mets are playing
the Knicks in sports and John claxon
perfect all right guys I said
appreciate you watching lunch money
we're gonna give plenty of sports
education before the next episode while
Wall Street is trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right what please be kind referee
Pulido wants me to tell you that and I
appreciate you guys all watching I have
been told you guys are doing a fantastic
job leaving comments I try to go
every night and respond as many as
possible the other thing that we were
told is please smash the like button
people keep telling me to say smash the
like button so go smash the like button
so YouTube will alright we gotta go
I appreciate you guys watching we'll see
you guys tomorrow